man that was some great athleticism kicks it
Dorothy Wizard of unbelievable play he got a
stick on it here's M again first penalty over
out of the box Mavis tipped to him shorthanded
score Mason Mavish a short-handed goal with 12
seconds left and the Ducks lead 43 unbelievable
unbelievable what a play by Adam Henri who poked
that puck to center ice just as McTavish came
out of the S bin and McTavish just picks
that corner over the glove unbelievable
Play here's Baleno Scar and a dart to the top
of the net yeah was that ever Ken there's no
you setting it up Boston just creates that
pressure in the middle of the rink where
you can't get there once you go to the
outside so why not take it to the hole
what a move by number 90 there in red in an
absolute perfect shot and the wings are back
in business drop for Everly Everly tried to get
it back but Brady Shay with a stellar defensive
play now Shay he's got his motor going Shay to
the backand across NES drops it back they scor
Brady Shay desperately makes the play kicks
it Dorothy Wizard of all style from his left
skate up to his tap heck of a pass and Nate
just makes an even better pass to Cen yamy
on his offside and in one motion cook and Amy
almost harpoons it into the back of the net
as soon as he let it go now Wilson delays finds
a trailing oetkin back door for strong and he
scores oh my goodness what a play brilliant
pass here by oetkin but well handled by Str
I cannot believe that he's able to get
control of it here after he falls down
it's not quite the oetkin goal in Arizona
his rookie year but man that was some great
athleticism there by stro who's picked up an
assist already tonight tip score shot by a h
by aimon he battles for everything and this
is a battling goal kind of a typical one for
asimon even though he's getting shoved from
behind at the last second by Hoffman he gets
a stick on it and he redirects that that
was nasty for the goenda no chance on that
one here's Alex tuck plays it in front what a
play by T Thompson are you kidding me what a
goal as he danced his way around VCH van and
buries it probably the prettiest one of the
Year here so far he's such a big man he's got
such nice moves and they're going to find Tage
Thompson going to the net and just watch
how he reaches out pulls it up below the
goal line back above the goal line pass V
vanich and slides it into the net on his
forehand a with the puck on his hip and scores
torture chimber he's going to slow it down
right between the hash marks the pump fake get the
golender to fight a little bit just enough to get
down into that butterfly and then elevate short
si side top shelf under the crossbar huge huge
goal for Boston to the slot great back check Deon
Shaw away from Brendan Lemieux on a line change
and camped out Sha's in he scor this thing was
going to go down and be iceing they were never
going to get a chance he knocks this Puck out of
midair and he settles it down and what a play he
goes forehand backhand five hole smooth Ms there
by Shore little chip a nice one gour mcan's in
for a chance he scores that's hockey baby what a
goal by Jared mccan look at this little beautiful
touch pass it bypasses two Florida Panthers and
caner goes to the backand he brings it back over
to his forehand and then he goes backhand right
into the wide open net and avoids the net just
a beautiful play sha dery will bring it in now
dery to the fridy Stars holy who did he blow the
doors off of and this is where dery is dangerous
and he does it against his former team how good
does that feel get the puck down the left side
right-handed shot drives to the net on his back
hand to the forehand and right through talin what
a goal oh yeah he's loving it KN if it's back the
backand P they score what a play Morgan Riley
the goal book neander had back there with two
defensemen causes them to stop the puck gets
a Little Help From Austin Matthews by time and
space and then dander what SPS Riley getting lost
Joe kelki been around a long time gets caught off
watching he's staring right at William helander
he's got no idea that his guy slipped in behind
him brilliant feed and goal that skipped away from
him and a nice dive to keep it alive Ry shoot tip
score foring on the deflection after a great keep
at the line by n so close to getting out and a
clear and Matthew n's a bit of a high-risk move
to dive cuz if you miss you slow it down maybe
there's a break opportunity Morgan riy all over
the offense tonight he places this Puck down for
to two snared by vasic and now Felino cter Bard
scores what a play in the defensive Zone to get
this thing started the pushup right there by
blassic just an intelligent play didn't bail
off put the puck ahead and a super sweet pass by
Felina kind of the hook of his blade right there
and he poked it by and put it in a perfect spot
to a streaking Bard lethal wrist shot thanks for
coming good stick by Hartman he's Off to the Races
Hartman on the Breakaway he scores it's a good
defensive play he hustles to get out there nice
stick breaks it up and that's Off to the Races he
loads this stick up making keer think he's going
to shoot it that freezes temper enough and then
it's quick hands to the backand hold it just for
a second get it around the pad deposit it in the
Ning crew gave it away to P pass Miller's alone
short handed GT Miller scores dangerous dual on
the penalty kill pson is able to come up with the
ptle sa pass M holds for long enough to hit pton
down and then the backand Finish jaru set that
through now Sula but the side of the goal kach
scores Brady had time looked like he was going to
use too much time but then got the backand on it
and the captain does a great job showing Poise
forehand doesn't work I'll go to the backand
Thank you very very much beats hellberg brilliant
brilliant play by Brady kachuck between Winnipeg
and Montreal the Jets looking to score they do
Lowry with his second of the game the goahead
goal now for Lowry nudge around as he poked
around with his stick on it fr the shot face
the Adam Lowry with his second of the night nobody
takes him and look at he's got half the net and
Jake Allen is so slow coming back that Lowry has
half the net at least to put it in set to return
weer able to work his way through and skino scores
on the rebound this is just taking matters into
your own end look at The Pedestrian D there for
the Edmonton ERS as EOL gets standing still and
weager just jumps right through now you bring
a body to you on the back check and you forget
about the guy who just came on From the Bench
as Greer gets lost in the shuffle and pounces
on the rebound Bret carries in wrestled away from
him by cikis forbat hustling cus has a step he's
in it's in a shorthanded goal that was a great
play by Casey and once he got hold of the puck
close right in on De Bret steal the puck and then
watch Casey he doesn't hesitate he just goes hard
hard hard out skates and then tries to go five
home successful make a stick handling play in
the for with he get it in the slot send it cross
with the score oh what a pass from speet nikov
ten three passes speet nikov makes another
brilliant pass when you're thinking shitty
shoot the puck really good play from orloff
and off balance n is able to open up Carter
heart backhand forehand and score outstanding
Puck movement in the Philadelphia [Music] Zone